[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les femmes c'est du
chinois le comprenez-vous moi pas
celle-ci est une
gamine qui tient tellement à sa peau
qu'elle baisse ses yeux en creux de
Chine mais jamais son kimone
les femmes c'est du
chinois le comenez-vous moi pas cellelà
est une
acrobate qui la nuit fait du
duu il faut vous accrocher à
cesates sinon celle qui prend le
dessus les femes c'est du
chinois le comprenez-vous moi pas
celle-ci est une
fillette qu'on ne mange pas avec les
doigts il faut la prendre avec des
baguettes sinon elle ne veut pas les
femmeses c'est du
chinois le comprenez-vous moi pas tel
autre quand elle sec couche et ta vide
de
sensation vous riez la fine mouche
compte les autres au
plafond les femmes c'est du
chinois le comprenez-vous moi pas
celle-là quand elle perd la bataille
pour ne pas se donner à
l'ennemi de votre sabre de samouraï
elle se fait
arir les
femmes
chinois le comprenez-vous moi pas à
genou vous demande grâces mais celle-ci
rien ne la
tendrit il vous faut mourir par
contumasse au 13e coup de
minuit les femmes c'est du
chinois le comprenez-vous moi
pas
[Musique]